más imágenes de las tropas ucranianas
que afirman haber retomado territorios
los soldados y sant aquí la bandera
ucraniana en una ciudad del sur de la
región de jarquín
como se baja
nuestra visión control youtube
y otro vídeo esté compartido por el
presidente volodymyr selenski muestra la
bandera ondeando desde una torre de
antena schelowsky ciento kilómetros más
al norte
se le calificó la retirada de rusia de
los centros logísticos clave de visión
jones que el sábado como un gran avance
en la guerra en una rueda de prensa dijo
que un mayor número de armas podría
significar un avance más rápido
sin embargo creo que este invierno es un
punto de inflexión y puede conducir a la
rápida desocupación de ucrania vemos
como las fuerzas rusas están huyendo en
diferentes direcciones si fuéramos un
poco más fuertes con las armas podríamos
desocupar más rápido
rusia dijo haber respondido con varios
ataques en jarquín y en otras zonas
las fuerzas rusas han llevado a cabo
ataques de alta precisión
las pérdidas del enemigo se hundieron a
más de dos centenares de militares y más
de 20 unidades de equipo militar las
autoridades ucranianas parecieron a
refutar las afirmaciones de rusia de que
se habían alcanzado objetivos militares
aquí en la ciudad sureña de nikolai
varios civiles resultaron heridos en un
ataque a primera hora del domingo contra
una zona residencial